THEY ARE PAYING THE BILLS.
CONGRESSMAN, GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT, THANK YOU FOR STANDING
STRONG WITH THAT COMMISSION PAID
THE LEFT IS ALSO USING
JANUARY 6TH AS A PRETEXT, OF
COURSE TO COMPLETELY REMAKE OUR
MILITARY AND TARGET
CONSERVATIVES IN THE RANKS.
>> THE JOB OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE IS TO KEEP AMERICA SAFE
FROM OUR ENEMIES.
BUT WE CAN'T DO THAT IF SOME OF
THOSE ENEMIES LIE WITHIN OUR OWN
RANKS.
WE ARE ALSO TACKLING THE PROBLEM
OF VIOLENT EXTREMISM.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE
EXTREMISTS RUNNING THE PENTAGON?
JOINING ME NOW, TOM COTTON OF
THE ARMED SERVICES COMMITTEE.
VERY CLEAR ON HIM THEY'RE TRYING
TO PURGE.
SO WHY SHOULD REPUBLICANS
RUBBER-STAMP FUNDING FOR A
MILITARY THAT IS BEING TURNED
INTO THIS WOKE OF FIVE FACTORY
BRANDING CONSERVATIVES AS
EXTREMISTS?
>> LAURA, WE ARE NOT GOING TO IN
THE WEEKS AHEAD AS WE -- I'M
GOING TO TAKE UP THIS MATTER.
I'VE ARTIE INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD FORBID
THE MILITARY FROM TEACHING
CRITICAL RACE THEORY AT OUR
PROFESSIONAL MILITARY SCHOOLS.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT COULD BE
MORE DIVISIVE, MORE DESTRUCTIVE
OF MORALE.
SAYING SOME RACISTS ARE
INHERENTLY OPPRESSED OR
VICTIMIZED BEER THAT'S THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE SHOULD BE
TEACHING OUR YOUNG -- WHAT WE
WANT TO TEACH THEM IS TO LOVE
THEIR COUNTRY, DEFEND THE
COUNTRY, AND LOOK AT THE MANNER
THE WOMAN ON THE RIGHT OR LEFT
AS A FELLOW --
>> Laura: I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT, BUT YOU WON'T GET
THAT PAST.
THAT IS A GREAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION, BUT WHEN BIDEN'S
PRESIDENT AND NANCY IN CHARGE OF
THE HOUSE, YOU CAN PREVENT THE
FUNDING OF THIS.
SO IF YOU GUYS HOLD UP THE
FUNDING, THEY ARE SUDDENLY GOING
TO LIFT THEM.
WILL YOU DO THAT?
>> THAT MAY BE A STEP WE HAVE TO
TAKE, BUT I WON'T SAY WE CAN'T
GET IT PASSED.
REMEMBER, THE DEFENSE BILL
PASSES EVERY YEAR, AND HAS EVERY
YEAR FOR 60 YEARS.
WE HAVE AN EMINENT PROCESS AND
THE COMMITTEE AND ON THE FLOOR
BUT THERE MAY BE ONE OR TWO
DEMOCRATS WHO DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD BE TEACHING OUR TROOPS
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING ABOUT
THEM IS THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN
RATHER THAN THEIR ABILITY TO
HELP SAVE THE LIVES OF THE MEN
AND WOMEN TO THE RIGHT AND TO
THEIR LEFT.
WE GET ALL KINDS OF CALLS AND
LETTERS AND EMAILS COMING INTO
MY OFFICE.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE ALL TROOPERS
TONIGHT, IF THEY ARE BEING
INDOCTRINATED WITH THIS KIND OF
NONSENSE, TO CONTACT.
CONTACT SENATE.GOV.
WE WELCOME WHISTLE-BLOWERS, YOU
CAN SEND IN YOUR EXPERIENCES.
YOU CAN SEND IN DOCUMENTS THAT
ARE BEING SEEN.
WE WANT TO STAND UP FOR YOU, WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU ARE
SPENDING YOUR TIME TRAINING TO
FIGHT AND TO WIN AND TO TAKE
CARE OF YOUR BATTLE BUDDIES.
>> Laura: THE SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE -- HE'S CALLING THE
TROOPS THE ENEMY.
I HAD NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD BE
IN A COUNTRY WHERE THE SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE WOULD CALL OUR
TROOPS, SOME OF THEM, THE ENEMY.
I HOPE EVERYBODY LISTENED TO
THAT CLIP.
IF YOU MISSED IT WHEN WE PLAYED
IT BEFORE.
BUT I'VE GOT TO ASK YOU, THIS
NEW WEAR PORTS FROM THE
INTERCEPT IS REVEALING
SENATOR THAT THE PENTAGON IS
LAUNCHING A PILOT PROGRAM TO
MONITOR THE SOCIAL MEDIA
ACCOUNTS OF OUR MILITARY
PERSONNEL FOR EXTREMISM.
SO HE DENIED IT, BUT THEN HE
ADDED THIS.
>> THERE'S NO EFFORT INSIDE THIS
EXTREMIST WORKING GROUP TO
SOMEHOW SPY ON EVERY INDIVIDUAL
IN THE MILITARY OR SPEND HOURS
AND HOURS JUST GETTING THROUGH
SOCIAL MEDIA ACTIVITY JUST FOR
THE SAKE OF DOING IT.
BUT WE ARE INTERESTED IN DOING
IS SEEING HOW THE SERVICES ARE
DOING AS A RECRUIT, SEE IF
THERE'S THINGS THAT CAN BE
LEARNED, THINGS THAT CAN BE
IMPROVED.
>> Laura: TO YOU BY THAT?
>> WE ARE GOING TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THAT, BECAUSE LOOK,
THE MILITARY HAS ALWAYS SCREAMED
FOR EXTREMISTS.
YOU HAD TO WRITE DOWN WHAT
TATTOOS YOU HAD COME AND MAKE
SURE THERE WEREN'T ANY GANG
TATTOOS BEING ENLISTED IN THE
MILITARY.
BUT IF THE MILITARY WAS
PROPOSING TO ACTIVELY MONITOR
SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS OF OUR
TROOPERS ON AN ONGOING BASIS TO
LOOK FOR PARTISAN OR POLITICAL
STATEMENTS, THAT WOULD BE AN
EXTREME OVERREACH, WHICH
WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED.
WE ARE GOING TO BE GETTING
ANSWERS TO THESE QUESTIONS SOON.
>> Laura: WHO KNOWS BETTER